seriously like he smells like granola
and good living as the celebrity hygiene
debate rages on yvette nicole brown just
entered the chat dishing on her tropic
thunder co-star matthew mcconaughey who
has been vocal in the past about his
decision not to wear deodorant i love it
i'm happy the actress recently appeared
on siriusxm's the jess kegel show and as
other stars discussed their bathing
habits matthew's own routine came back
to the forefront of conversation when
yvette opened up about making it her
mission to smell the oscar winner on the
set of their 2008 film vivica get off
the line now
i remember that matthew mcconaughey said
that he did not use deodorant and that
he didn't have an odor so my first
thought was i'm going to get as close as
i can to him to see if he's right the
verdict
he does that odor he smells seriously
like he smells like granola and good
living
he has a sweet sweet scent that is just
him and it's it's not musty or crazy
like yvette said the dallas buyers club
star has been open about his decision to
forgo deodorant in fact during a 2005
interview for his people's sexiest man
alive cover the actor was asked what a
man should smell like and his answer was
simple a man adding quote i haven't worn
deodorant in 20 years no deodorant sure
but yvette says he does shower not
really he bathes because he smelled
delicious he just didn't have deodorant
on those that don't babe i don't
understand of course this recent focus
on hygiene comes after ashton kutcher
and mila kunis made headlines in july
for revealing how often they bathe their
children during an episode of dax
shepherd's armchair expert podcast if
you can see the dirt on them clean them
yeah otherwise there's no point when i
had children i also didn't wash them
every day like i wasn't the parent that
bathed my newborns
ever as for dax and his wife kristen
bell they agreed with their pals during
an appearance on the view i'm a big fan
of waiting for the stake once you catch
a whiff that's
that's biology's way of letting you know
you need to clean it up and all that
sparked what i'm calling the big online
bathing debate jake gyllenhaal revealed
he doesn't shower much confessing to
vanity fair that more and more he finds
bathing to be quote less necessary at
times dwayne the rock johnson confirmed
he's on team shower and even tweeted his
entire hygiene routine also on team
shower drew barrymore who tossed her
opinion into the great bathing debate
during a recent chat with e.t
oh my god i
listen i i've got two girls and the
shoes i've got some odor eaters
you know
it can get real
do you do they bathe every day
my kids yes uh during the week yeah
absolutely right on weekends i'm a
little more relaxed
again i'm just looking for balance for
me i'm like you were at school all day
bath every night absolutely and then on
the weekends it's like you were in the
salty ocean like who cares you're fine
or
whatever but i i guess i'm a five day a
weeker with a possible six underwear
yeah but five to six days a week and
when it comes to matthew back in march
drew didn't dish on his hygiene habits
but she did recall what it was like
starring alongside him in the 1995 flick
boys on the side i'm going to stand by
holly 100 percent but i am sworn to
uphold the law
i don't believe i would be any use to
her whatsoever if i broke my oath now
would i
he really loves me
we all knew he was going to be a big
star we just knew it he was too dynamic
and he worked really hard on his
character and he brought these really
surprising turns
with the character and he played it
really straight but then at night when
he was off duty he was like you know
tequila and bongos so i knew that he
wasn't playing himself and that he had
created this character and he was very
serious about his work and he was just
dripping with charisma and i was like we
all were like yeah biggest movie star
ever right here
[Music]
you